con cartuchos de dinamita petardos
piedras y palos protestaron agricultores
cocaleros en la ciudad boliviana de la
paz ocho días de enfrentamiento con la
policía dejan decenas de heridos y
varios detenidos incluyendo periodistas
los cocaleros muestran su descontento
por la autoproclamación de arnold alan
es un líder al final gobierno como
dirigente de la asociación departamental
de productores de coca uno de los dos
mercados reconocidos por una ley que
rige el comercio de esta planta de uso
tradicional el nombramiento fue
calificado como un intento del gobierno
de apoderarse del sector privado
cocalero
[Risas]
este gobierno es un tirano
a pesar de que los vecinos de la zona
han sacado sus banderas blancas
exigiendo el cese de la violencia los
ánimos de los manifestantes no se
apaciguan mientras que organizaciones de
derechos humanos condenan el uso
excesivo de la fuerza el gobierno
reprochó los daños materiales que hasta
el lunes podían ascender los 40 mil
dólares tras entregar las más escasas
nuestras guaguas es andrés maya nos den
son los cuartos
tenemos que quemar en nuestras casas qué
le pasa al gobierno se estima que en
bolivia hay más de 100.000 plantaciones
de coca un cultivo legal en algunas
zonas del país y que sirve para ser más
caro infusión y rituales religiosos